قصه انتقال رونالدو الى السعوديه تعود
باصداء قويه الاحاديث كثيره ومتابعوه
الكره العالميه ربما ينتظرون انتقالا
تاريخيا للاعب الابرز في تاريخ اللعبه
الحديث الحكايه بدات الصيف الماضي مع
انباء عن وجود عرض سعودي للنجم البرتغالي
الذي بدات مشاكله مع نادي مانشستر يونايتد
في ذلك الوقت رونالدو حينها كان يرغب
بالرحيل عن اليونايتد الذي لم يتاهل لدوري
ابطال اوروبا فرق ابواب انديه اوروبيه
اخرى وحاول الخروج لكن اداره يونايتد لم
تقبل وراتبه المرتفع حاله دون انتقاله
لانديه اخرى انتهت فتره الانتقالات استمر
رونالدو في الاشهر الاولى من الموسم
الجديد مع مانشستر يونايتد العلاقه كانت
بارده مع الاداره ومدرب النادي ختمها
رونالدو بتصريحات سبقت كاس العالم هاجم
فيها قتل نادي والمدرب الانجليزيه بدا كاس
العالم الاهتمامات منصبه على اهم حدث
عالمي لكن حكايه اقتراب بانتقال رونالدو
من نادي النصر السعودي سرقت بعض الاضواء
من المونديال حيث الصفقه التي يقدرها
البعض باكثر من 250 مليون دولار امريكي
لمده ثلاث سنوات
[موسيقى]